on the snow-capped mountains of Venus
there's no actual snow as we know it
because it snows metal and ellipses is a
designer kitchen pod concept to grow
your own insects to eat Vsauce Kevin
here this is mine
a professor at the University of
Nottingham discovered a new human body
part a sixth layer of the cornea he's
calling it duas layer named after
himself and the discovery means that up
Tamala G textbooks will have to be
rewritten and clinicians around the
world are already beginning to relate
many diseases to the discovery of this
new layer a Chinese construction firm
has been given the go-ahead to create
the world's tallest skyscraper called
Sky City it'll be two hundred and twenty
stories in two thousand seven hundred
and fifty feet tall and when finished
will be the size of a small city it'll
have a hundred and four elevators and a
six mile ramp that will lead 30,000
people towards the schools hospitals and
housing and they also plan to construct
it in only seven months we see is an
interaction interface that is able to
recognize human gestures throughout the
home using Wi-Fi and a few mobile
devices we see can identify gestures in
line-of-sight non line of sight and
through the wall scenarios the prototype
was able to identify and classify a set
of nine gestures with a 94% accuracy and
they see it being used to control music
TV lights and heating anywhere in the
home world's oldest primate fossil ever
found and it was the size of a mouse
Lego is working with Sony to create toys
that are more like video games to keep
younger kids interested though still in
the planning phases some of the ideas
are to have the LEGO pieces mounted to
small motors and cameras the tiny device
is controlled with a video game
controller and the enemy devices are
controlled by a computer they're working
on having the cameras linked to a smart
device so you can see what your toy is
seeing and also developing parts and
pieces that can be ejected or blown up
university of minnesota's biomedical
engineering professor bing he created a
non-invasive brain computer interface
that allows the user to control a robot
using only their
I seen here being guided around a gym
turning rising and even flying through
balloon rings the hope is to use this
technology for those with
neurodegenerative diseases to regain
function by controlling artificial limbs
or other devices a new reversible male
contraceptive proven effective in mice
testicles involves injecting gold
nanorods and feeding them up so yeah
DARPA has created new nerve and muscle
interfaces that can be controlled
directly through amputees existing
nerves the project is called re net
reliable neural interface technology and
they're hoping to not only create
high-performance interfaces that are
reliable they want to provide sensory
feedback that would also give the user
the ability to feel the Emperor 1510 LX
is a $21,500 hi-tech workstation it has
a retractable monitor stand that can
hold five monitors a reclining Italian
leather seat with thigh rest Bose sound
system and a cup holder Tokyo has
underground bike parking structures made
by a company named gaiking that can take
your bike into a cylinder that protects
it from theft vandalism and inclement
weather using a magnetic key for access
the door clamps onto the front wheel of
the bike and takes it underground onto a
platform each station is able to hold
about 200 bikes and guy can hopes to
create many more of these in the future
but finding underground space in Tokyo
could pose a problem finally Michael Ben
ski shot this incredible footage of a
supercell near booker texas
I'm gonna leave you with kilobots having
a picnic in as always thanks for
watching